everybody my ex camera um all right hi
my name is Nick and the name of this
presentation is a brief history of
Reaper formance and that's what it's
about it's a very brief history in this
case the thought of crunching 100 100
page paper into a 20-minute presentation
so right now I'm a little bit deep in
the in tall grass so I've tried to link
simplify things a lot so I may have
dropped things that are required to make
sense of certain parts with this so if
anything doesn't make sense or if you
want more detail let me know I erred on
the side as implicitly with I hope that
stuff can come out in the Q&A if you
really wanted it so I'm interested in
music reproduction and in the standard
way of thinking about it now we sort of
have had two ways of reproducing music
first is with performance with music
notation and performers if you want to
make a piece of music happen again you
have a performer and a score I do with
this courses and now you have a piece of
music one more time and the other way
which I'm pretty sure you're all
familiar with is with speakers of like
this that produce sound waves in the air
directly um and these speakers and other
similar technologies that vibrate little
membranes in May in May primary little
membranes really needs a pair are
modeled on this which is the tympanic
membrane or your eardrum and so Jonathan
starting calls these kinds of
technologies tympanic reproductions so
they're based on the tympanum the human
ear drum so a lot of the way that we
talk about sound and reproduction and
sort of related issues is based on this
is based on make sort of makes sense
based on here based on technologies that
are based on the ear so what I'm
interested in doing is looking at a
different kind of reproduction I kind of
not the dominant not successful not the
current but an older obsolete residual
all of these great sort of marginalizing
words and specifically further for the
purposes of this presentation
we're looking at this machine of Edwin's
got voters 1897 pianola which is a
machine that plays your piano for you if
you look up here patent diagrams are
great the one a thin black line up there
burning and nine that's a key on a piano
so you stick this thing up in front of
your piano it's got a v8 fingers with
little health tips on them and it
presses down keys you put your feet on
this pedal you come pen um that makes
the keys go and what actually is are
directly makes the keys go is that this
piece of paper with holes in it rolls
over a bar that also has holes in it and
when the holes in the paper lined up
with the holes on the bar then a vacuum
pulls through and the corresponding node
gets hit so now you know exactly how
player panels work um it looks sort of
like this general I think I use this in
my last presentation this woman his
client in although just playing her a
piano for her daughter um and so she's
doing stuff with her hands that will
become important later so before i get
into the ugly details of this um i want
to sort of get out the question which is
sort of inherent in a lot of this
historical work why do we care why do we
care about a strange machine that's
invented over a hundred years ago that
we don't use today and all this what
does it have to tell us about where we
are now why would we care about old
things as if i have defended that's okay
i will oh so i don't say that the
argument for why we care is because it
is strange because it seems strange and
it's uncommon and we can discover
alternative ways of looking at sound
reproduction so I think that Reaper
formats which is this mode of
reproduction what I think
pre-performance offers is an opportunity
it is an opportunity to look at sound
reproduction to think about sound
reproduction in unusual terms and so a
lot of the purpose of my thesis is about
enabling exploration and enabling a kind
of inventiveness in the way that we
conceive of sound and material sound and
reported sound so the central theme of
this presentation is going to be about
recordings and performance those first
two modes and bringing them together and
the way that happens will become
hopefully more clear so there are two
primary areas in which I think
the picket wall for this presentation
there are two primary areas in which i
think the piano that has something
interesting to offer us about in this in
this area okay so first representation
the way that performance is represented
on paper the way performance is fixed in
order to be reproduced a second
reconfiguration this is the way that
performance is actually altered in order
to be reproduced so in order to make a
piano performance happen again you need
to do something to the piano performance
and Shane VIP from its original form and
I'm interested in those two things are
broadly sort of about representation of
reconfiguration but about perception in
labor so back to our friend the role
this is the sort of fundamental thing
about representation in the you know and
it I know people in the grad students
have read this article by at least a
gintleman about a mankini 06 court case
which is about these very things and the
question was are these sheet music are
not and there's a debate it's all about
money in the end between composers and
sheet music publishers and music roll
producers and the musical producers say
this is not music because if it was
sheet music they would have to pay
royalties to the composers and so they
said this isn't music this is machine
parts it's in a machine it moves around
in the machine the music roll producer
said no you can see look there's are the
notes that you can't read it though so
it's not legible the humans but so the
question in this in this room the court
ended up deciding that it was machine
parts actually which is funny one
analogy with the phonograph because the
photograph is not sheet music so there's
sort of knew about media studies axios
that we think about new media in terms
of ecole this is actually newer than the
phonograph so there was a sense of
making sense of this via the photograph
um but so the question got then resolved
the other way by the 1909 Copyright Act
which said actually no these are all new
kind of mechanical reproduction let's
have a thing called mechanical licenses
and force everyone to to pay this a
little bit of money in case I don't care
about copyright I'm sorry so so the
question that I think is interesting
here is about legibility and what does
it mean really be machined legible and
words they personally be human legible
and I
that that is a sort of negotiable
negotiable thing that holes are
obviously machine-readable in a certain
way these liens on the paper are human
readable and not machine readable I'll
get back to them in a moment but even
while musical producers are saying
things like these are machining parts
they're doing all of this work this
hybridizing work to make these legible
to humans so you find it mentions like
this which is you know printing music
across the front of the across the part
of the role so that when you when you're
sitting at the piano you can look at it
and see the music right though music
meaning traditional musical notation
there are a variety of ways to do this
that chop up musical notation alter it
this is one that one this is another one
then this one brings up an interesting
sort of extra step where in addition to
showing music on the screen they also
show you what to do this is a piano
instruction roll it will teach you how
to play the piano presumably after
you've taken the thing off the funky
cookies before you sit want to build in
a built-in player so it says you know
here's the holdups this note press it
with your finger and so on and even more
exciting one which is this which tells
you how to not to play the piano and how
to operate the pianola itself you notice
the foot on the pedal is what's the
bottom because you won't get very hard
you don't realize that you need to press
the pedal trip to the perfect into a
nice um so returning back to this sort
of this thing look above of these lawns
there are two lines there's a dotted
line and there's a sort of solid wavy
line the dotted line represents dynamic
level and will be printed on the role
because if you pedal harder or pedal
softer you can make the music louder or
quieter and how do you decide whether it
should be louder or fighter oh well you
can read the sort of line on it and what
that line tells you okay let's let's get
to read about reconfiguration is what
the line tells you is you know what to
do so the now the role is instructing
both the machine and you in how does it
come together and produce this Reed
performance of something that's already
been stuck on the piece of paper what
the I won't get to the solid line just
yet so what this does is changes the
interface of the piano from this you
used to need to know how to manage this
thing to play the piano if you
to be a pianist to this so now you can
be a peon oldest who is someone plays
the piano and this is what the woman was
operating with her hands and what that
wavy line was was joy so these are some
hand controls you can control the
sustain pedal because your fever busy
you can change the tempo you can make
the high notes louder or the low notes
letter this varies tremendously across
all of these machines but what I'm
interested in at the moment it's this
one this is the tempo letter with an
added thing that points up it's called
the Metro style because it is the
metronome stylist I had changes the
tempo if you track that line with it and
as you track that line a music speeds up
or slows down and the reason that you
need to have this is because at the time
most piano rolls were metronomic we
punch which means they take sheet music
and directly turn it into the piano as
you would say there's four quarter notes
in a row you have four holes giving me
space nobody plays like that those have
also come out evenly and even dynamic
level like they would be exactly the
same loudness and so at the time there's
a question how can we make this
mechanical thing more or human and the
interesting answer at this time is with
the human in front of it and so what you
do is you tell the human wiggle this
little stick and the temple is going to
go like this and that will sound more
human Barry the dynamic level and then
that will something will send more human
so reintroducing variability by actually
using by using a person what's really
interesting about the metro-style on
notice that they're not only just are
drawn on there by you know the guy who
says now it gets better netting it's
lowered not recording the score but
they're recorded sometimes or drawn on
by experts so a famous pianist would
take this role of the score and they say
okay interpret this it would take a pen
and they would write on the role whether
where they would go faster or slower so
now what the pianist's job is now that
the machine can remember the notes the
pianist job is to say okay i want to say
within dynamic level and was the what
the tempo is so that's now the locus of
human pianistic performance is being
refurbishing these two these two things
so they would record it on they would
record it by using things
this if you're not familiar with the
insides of pianos this majors like the
inside of a piano but the thing up there
above the hammer number 10 is a
recording device that if you hit the
strip at Hamburg that will tell you how
fast you the strength therefore tell you
how loud and then we'll mark a roll and
instead of having the holes be evenly
spaced it will be spaced around the head
plate so it's if they call it a hand and
so this developed this this causes a
very interesting phenomena which is what
you are interpreting or playing when
you're on the pianola as a piano liz has
occasionally already been performed so
you are playing or recording in the sort
of traditional sense we are familiar
with playing recording because we
probably do it all the time you really
did it this morning before you came here
you know in some capacity of the shower
or the car whatever and so but now what
you're doing what you're performing has
already been performed one time so
there's a little bit of interesting
language so if that happens here it
happens throughout sort of the rest of
the pieces which points to what I
mentioned before about how to panic
reproduction really organizes the way we
think about about sound and reproduction
so we know what words like playback
interpretation liveness and performance
meetin right those all have mean so like
liveness for example music can't be live
until it can be recorded so you don't
have live music until there's a recorded
music that sort of produces live music
so there's a distinction between maybe
you know improvised music music that's
been written down I get to that a little
bit but there's no you know what's it
mean to be live so live music is
fundamentally based on recorded music
and when the recorded music is recorded
in a particular way liveness is
constructed in a particular way so the
kind of liveness that is complementary
to to assort salad traditional sound
recording tympanic the kind of email
with the speakers that's one kind of
lightness but say what is live mean in
what is living in this situation right
this guy is going to play the piano live
with might be playing someone else's
interpretation is being told what to do
by the machine doesn't have to do with
the machine says so there's a certain
interpretive to rid of flexibility and
what you have is this strange overlap
like I sort of hinted at
between recording and performance where
recordings are made in to be sort of
objects that can be performed again and
the opposition that we have between
performance and recording that I sort of
casually throughout in the beginning is
a way that we often think about Samuel
live versus recorded is sort of a
fundamental paradigm and how people
think about music when they listen to it
this doesn't make sense so what you have
at the time is confusion about this
because they do have live and recorded
music when the pianola comes out they
have the phonograph the photograph has
been around and so the advertisers have
this question and they say well how are
going to sell this machine we're going
to sell it as hey you remember the notes
if a baby crawled onto the pedals who
started pushing then the baby could play
or our witness I wish I had a picture of
these head like this ad but I can find
it or are we going to say what trust me
once it says this you're not an operator
you are a player with this device so
they're trying to say now you're not you
know you're not consuming things you are
actually producing something I actually
performing something and so in recent
literature on the player piano on
mechanical music specifically a book by
a guy named Brian Dolan and an article
by David sweetman there's a talk about d
skilling as what this is so you don't
have to remember the notes so now you
have less skip or it requires much skill
to do and as someone with media studies
you may be able to imagine where I go on
this on this issue about you know
consumption versus versus production and
I'm interested in sort of reclaiming
what people are doing when they're
sitting at the p.m. and so people who
are sitting at the piano are doing
something and what this because the
Machine becomes more complicated doesn't
mean that you have to become less
complicated in some way you can still
interact but I'm interested in sort of
reclaiming the performativity of
recordings which is sort of obvious
thing in this case because it's a
recording and performing but it's not so
obvious in the case of safe playing your
boom box on the subway or in terms of
you know putting the needle on a record
but a lot of these things are ten have
interesting parallels um so basically by
blending together traditional notions of
recording and performance we can
I want me together recording performance
we can replace or reconsider our models
of skill or models of what performance
is of what of what recording is and sort
move into the brave new world of overlap
II performative performativity and
recording now this I don't know how many
of you got to see the Gutenberg
parenthesis um talked yesterday uh but
I'm going to go out this is going to be
so there's there is a structural
similarity between what I'm saying and
some of the points of the cupboard and
apprentices people which is which is to
say that the idea that recording and
performance are these in violent
separate things is historically local
and technologically local and is only
true of recording it's not even true
phonographic recording at the beginning
of it it's true recording you know from
the early so no early 1900s through you
might say like the advent of turntablism
from the 70s this don't touch the record
recording performance or different kind
of idea but before that when is great
production means notation and
performance you know reinterpreting
other people's creative work as part
performance is you know the way that you
do things and now it's part of the way
we do things again this is part of them
the patent document for rock band like
really hard to see but this is what
patents look like now compared to how
they used to it um yeah so sort of in in
conclusion and trying to lead on to
questions I think that what's
interesting about re performance is this
alternate view point it gives us on the
way things are going now on technologies
that overlap performance and recording
in rock band you're playing but you're
also playing things that have been
recorded and people get upset about this
people say this isn't music this isn't
performance this isn't all sorts of
things but without considering where
those terms come from sort of historic
ality of performance actually there's
something that's been defined by and
against recording so I think that by
sort of blending together these things
by looking at me performance it is
coming back actually in some sort of
high by communities I didn't get to talk
about
company that takes old acoustic
recordings and turns them into player
piano recordings modern fancy player
people to their better recordings but
there are also new pieces but basically
this is sort of in the theme of a lot of
our lot of our presentations so far
about opening up a room for exploration
opening up room for inventiveness and
blurring the lines between categories
that were previously thought to be
completely you know incommensurable or
disagreement and now we're moving I
would just like to answer questions and
downloaded from the internet I can give
it to you later as a real [ __ ] yes
Elliot all right um so I actually might
have already asked you about this longer
day but I'm going to go for it up I
don't know if you're familiar with one
of the early harmonics projects before
they actually got into video games
they're giving a presentation with my
team talk about it dead their original
product was they were trying to sell a
variation of karaoke machines right hand
where you can actually sort of like it
all over you can actually control tempo
and other factors of music and the
market you know that the business people
Justin what are you doings you can
change recorded music 2238 if you think
there's a cultural factor that can
prevent your top of bringing someone
back and not that this is dependent on
finding market address but is there now
cultural resistance to changing I think
there absolutely is a cultural
resistance to changing it as an example
so that this company that I was talking
about that takes the old acoustic
recordings and turns them into the
player piano things they don't call
their player pianos player pianos their
pianos that play themselves but they
hold of robotic pianos because it's the
president this company told me it's a
market disaster and you say a player
piano and it's a sort of goes to because
player pianos mean crappy
stuff but it's sort of a similar problem
where there's this ingrained idea of
what of what recordings are supposed to
be and this is where it gets a little
bit Gutenberg parenthesis he felt like
that these are sometimes being invited
that recordings are recordings so we
don't do anything but I mean the funny
thing with the karaoke example is that
there it was already karaoke right so
karaoke is already about inserting
yourself into the role of the singer and
I have stumped some stuff in another
section about the roles that are defined
in this and how people occupy different
roles differently shaped their all to
move in so singing is one thing but
being the bandleader is this weird is
this weird other thing but meanwhile no
one at the moment is terribly upset
about you know DJ's and turntablism
where you are you know we're all about
changing the tempos and and so yeah
there's certainly cultural resistance
but given my historical time frame I am
hitting it less than good that I would
have expected I'm got a jolt to me uh
yes I mean I'm interested obviously
right those reasons I'm curious it
seemed like the gestures move for
something like the obsolete it's largely
to produce and pragmatic or material
histories and things right so I'm
wondering if it also consensual or it
also a theoretical ya say like I see the
richness of whatever in different more
this largely something about getting yes
why actually that's thank you for them
because there is a broad theoretical
part of this that I decided whether I
was going to cut because I didn't trust
myself to be able to talk about it in
the comments but sort of generally yes
so there's there is a sort of
theoretical angle on just how we
perceive reproduction but as far as
history goes like the working history
I'm didn't like they're definitely in
relations between this and sort of
theoretical working on innovation and
how you know new technologies come about
that are interesting that are
interesting to be in this context and
also about the relationship between
people & automation and so theoretically
that's something that comes up all the
time obviously comes up in certain
Marxism clearly and market alienation is
something that I'm sort of dealing with
personally and in the context of the
suppressed bajan but yeah so it's more
the theoretical stuff that's coming up
is generally media history specific just
because I had to cut myself out of a
chunk somewhere but it's mostly about
how people relate to automation and to
automation and to the specifically the
automation of things in the cultural
sphere so like Marxism is great about
you know what happens with a job in the
factory is now done by a robot but
there's a different kind of attitude
here about what happens when playing the
piano is done by a machine on the one
hand it seems less dire because whatever
it's only heart but but on the other
hand it also seems more dire because art
is the human and like what does it mean
to have machines do the thing that are
the human and so yeah so there's this
kind of anxiety yeah and I think
specifically in the surfing
anthropological angle that I would have
loved to go deeper into here how people
respond specifically to automation so
maybe not so much making claims about
the nature of automation what automation
does to culture or how people and
automation are but more about how two
people negotiate this because the
pianola it exists it's a real thing
nowadays people think I don't think a
metaphor it send to throw a chair at
during a bar fight in the Western or
whatever but it's a real thing in
people's houses at the time and so part
of part of users excited by recovering
historical specificity and you get to
say halo this was a real thing it had
wheels and like you had to push it out
to your piano and so I think there's
like a lot of value Justin doing that
agents are reclaiming the thingness of
this thing yeah so one of the things you
talked about
is change from their case of a damn
keyboard to interface 17 all right folks
that people based but the other change
that's going on there is also that the
piano keyboard itself becomes not only
interface to people's hands but now to
achieve and it's relates to something
comments are just making about fear of
mechanization of playing piano but
there's something different about
creating plastic interfaces to existing
plays itself I'm wondering what the
implications of that Marvin Gaye on
keyboard which exclusively for the use
of human p.m players it's converted by
the canola into a piece of a mechanical
linkage so there there are two in terms
of women remember both of them when I
talk about the person so the first one
is just a sort of little thing that
relates to about how the whole thing
about glomming the there about plumbing
is on to the front of the piano there's
a example that I found from 1915 was a
bench that you put in front of the
pianola and you plug it into the wall
and it's got two little pegs that come
out of the front of it and it pedals
nolas for you so there's obviously this
is bizarre interest in having machines
that operate that operate other machines
and an earlier sort of tech that I was
taking in the thesis was to look at the
pianola as a kind of reading of the
interviews of the piano to physical
reading of the interface because look at
the piano when you say okay what are the
salient parts of this interface and then
if you look at the sort of business end
of the of the pianola you can see you
know in inverse what they thought was
the important was the important
connection here and so part of what I
blurred over in this in trying to focus
on a single device I didn't explain a
million devices while I was going
through this thank you to my CMS
colleagues for getting me on that is the
is the so people like to make it remove
piano players & player piano so this is
the piano player because you stick it on
the front of the piano a player piano at
the piano that has this mechanism all
built into the inside and those turn
into what
called reproducing pianos which
specifically they they automate this so
they have encodings on the side that
replace you entirely by by you know
moving tempo automatically with the role
and doing the dynamics on their own and
so that has really different reception
actually the reproducing universes the
pianola because the reproducing piano
again is this like listening thing now
you can have patter risking at your
house and he'll play you a song and you
can go sit over there and you can just
listen to him and I think by the time of
the reproducing piano you see a little
bit of this I would call it a tympanic
attitude kind of creep into how people
relate to these machines because like
you said it's no longer about
interfacing two machines together
looking machine that you could have
played yourself like you can with the
recruits engineers old but it sort of
piano that can play itself so well that
it doesn't mean you anymore and so
that's maybe where some of this anxiety
comes out we're in every time someone
wants to say well there's something
special about live performance or before
there's live performances English
something specially what extemporaneous
performance so let's capture that in
machine and then they do it and they go
oh no I killed the bird or whatever
because they might capture didn't now
it's not special anymore so they even by
the next thing when special so yeah I
think that's maybe what happened with
the reproducing piano is that it wasn't
special anymore because you didn't have
this there's this like erasure of the
human and there's a bit of work to try
to reclaim the performativity of the
reproducing piano in terms of lake say
in terms of sort of experimental
composition which I know people here
knows is a fancy of mine i wish i had
that as a sound good example now because
it was plenty of the head no sounds in
here but it would have been tympanic
anyway so it's not just me but i guess
the examples where people take the
reproducing piano and say what can we do
with this that humans can't do and then
move from there and then it's a
Liberatore as opposed to this like
crushing alienating so it's a weird
question of attitudes i think yeah I
think it I mean I keep thinking the
Turing test yeah
real that is actually automated and I'm
wondering if you get into any
discussions of automation creativity and
in some sense diametrically opposed and
yet in other ways during the Tory thing
moves up through to thank me the first
days in terms of create like automatic
creativity it would be really fun to get
into some of the like automatic
automatic composition things would have
been more kind of like Whitney's these
essentially from last year's they're
like sort of similar historical
relationships between algorithmic comsys
linking Mozart composed of things that
use dice to now moved stuff around and
give up agency you to serve outside
sources sometimes machines in that
nature that was that was long but no but
now I'm in terms of the Turing test
though there are actually concerts that
they would get at the time if you have
the reproducing piano here and you would
have the PMF over here and they would go
and sit at the piano and then they would
pretend to play and they would get up
while the thing was still fighting these
are like advertisements rightly in the
form of concerts and like all concerts
and they was they would compensate over
here there was keep by you go oh my gosh
that's amazing because there's something
visual about seeing about seeing the guy
there there's this thing that ghosts of
the player on him to go home man now
he's there and he's here and they're
amazing counsel if they haven't with the
phonograph also actually with the
photograph there's this question of like
really like you leave that that a 1910
phonograph sounds exactly like an
operatic tenor onstage like there's no
way that that could possibly be true
whereas with the piano there's this
other weird effect where piano sound
like pianos so the way it sounds
different like sort of this is another
thing that I get to talk about in the
other piece is not the presentation is
fidelity so what is fidelity
faithfulness in tympanic reproduction is
about this kind of sound waves in the
air being exactly the same in two
different places whereas this kind of
video is weird it's like something about
interpretation so now you need to be
true to someone's hands it's about the
true to their ears and so what does that
mean to be you know faithful to some
famous units
education and it's an open question I
mean they don't really figure it out
then there's there's a great great thing
we're so that when they automate the
dynamics they have to do it in steps
right they have all these fellows that
you can either claps all the bellows or
certain numbers combinations in the
bellows it's actually a ternary code
that's on the side of the inside of the
role that tells you your belt and at one
model can do 16 levels of nuance or
whatever they're trying to get this PhD
to come and report them they say you
have to record for a duo or where the
best we have 16 levels of nuance and he
says sorry i play with 17 levels of
nuance and so there's this interesting a
gap right between how much means do
things and how people do things that
they're currently trying to overcome and
if i was able to give a million
presentations and talk about this new
company this is a company that does the
robotic pianos where instead of having
60 levels of me once they now have three
hundred levels of three months and you
think maybe that is enough like what
happens now if that's actually enough
levels and nuance and so yeah so the
issues are it's persistent i can't
imagine it a lot of job although you
really feel like how when you get any
better than the ones they have math but
i'm sure that this baby thank you for
your presentation just some free
association what is it thank you very
very much involved with it to try to get
to think about this ghost you know hands
like you see you Monday so basically
it's a it's great and people market you
try to simulate a human resolution at
the system I think it's very interesting
because in society of results may be a
human SF and communist we have this idea
of presence of individual speakers so I
think there's and also I cannot think of
my maneki portfolio now they're like the
things like 20 feet are with their
parades with them listing the knocker 50
department so their military action are
others there is that one of the robotic
games in the building forgot how
appropriate students in the media lab
because there is all sorts of stuff that
comes into this from
terms of performance with the future
this understood but as far as Uranus
goes there is a question hearing is with
speakers also and again the telephone
radio all of this question are they are
there ghosts in these like weird this
can refuse what people can do therefore
it's this like uncanny version of a
person they're more there are ghosts so
this is the most common thing you can
imagine like in the ads it's just like
the piano and not only is the piano
player a ghost but it's in this person's
home and they're dancing have you been
to the haunted mansion in at Disneyland
they're dancing ghosts in the air in
this program house while the person is
playing in the advertisement this is
good right like I bring all these ghosts
because you know that's how realistic
humans to UM robot oh so again so i
forgot to say that there's that's the
other thing that's interesting i think
about this and about the way the thing
about sound reproduction so there's a
sort of geological model of San
reproduction we're like on a large level
tympanic reproduction is the best
because it's pure it's just exactly the
sounds in the care so it's completely
neutral but then there's this question
of you know the seat that the CD it's
better than the record between a blah
blah blah I'm is better than there's
always like different things that are
better than other places and if you will
forget that there's more than one way to
do stuff right like just because one of
these is successful doesn't mean that
everything else sucks so there are more
than one way to make an automatic piano
and some of the ways that people did
that usually prior this is if as an
entrance right so you have rhianwen at
heza has a piano playing android that's
in a museum somewhere in Europe now that
plays the piano when you think okay
that's interesting because automatic
pianos aren't just one and the same way
that sound reproduction is actually not
just one thing like you could make one
of the quotes that I put up in my last
presentation for getting of the year
with someone arguing for the player
piano by saying the piano is an
automatic hammered dulcimer anyway there
are strings and in the end adults where
you hit them with hammers the pianos
let's hit 88 strains with 88 hammers in
exactly the same way every time so lucky
you and now this is an automatic
automatic dulcimer and so on but the
automatic automatic dulcimer could be a
lot of things there are actually
automatic dulcimers right
that's a no B to have a little person go
and they you know their name to make
these panels so I'm this is about not
about like replacing can panic
reproduction or claiming some like other
alternative like trunk of history but
basically making a thicker sort of more
multi various kind of media history
specifically of this in this time period
when stuff is really thick there's this
idea that this is because it's obsolete
now it's always been obsolete and so the
people who use the therapy know that
must been dumb or something because they
didn't realize that that is really to us
you know so there's this interesting
that's really yes oh yeah and by that
you know music
musically like actually it's our
composition of language there is a
device home perforator that you could
get 19 teens maybe even a little bit
earlier um that was going to be actually
a focus of the pieces before I could I
have to keep going but there's this it's
a home perforator and it has a music
stand on it so it's sort of intended for
you to make your own roles from using
other people have already composed and
this elaborate they have like different
models right there's a little portable
one it's the iPhone or whatever for you
to like bring your friend says and
there's like bigger one that goes in the
cabinet and then you put the music on
it's got a fancy little more names to
Anna you there's a bunch of that it's
actually ratcheted across so it only
will punch you know right on where the
holders with me and then only its
resident this way too so homely on like
you know divisions notes so that you
don't have to worry about sloppy timing
then there's a big one that's for like
classrooms and I have these amazing
pictures of music teachers with all
these little kids punching rolls and I'm
not sure what that was supposed to do
but it's an interesting thought right
like i mentioned that with those sort of
hybrid things like this this is about
making music legible people and there's
some sense of this is what music is and
this is not what music is and that's a
whole a whole extra question but in the
in the classroom there's this weird
thought that maybe there was some motion
towards saying actually maybe music can
be this and like you know legibility is
relative so that you could learn how to
figure this out and people do things we
print with your groups on specific
here's a pray and seek observer you know
there's this like very hand motioning
kind of thought of a new expression
where it's like racism there's a
technology called audio graphic roles
where they print a music appreciation
stuff on it so on one hand will have the
words on the other hand will have this
person who we don't know who it is isn't
an expert telling you stuff both
musicals and get ready the bells are
coming and it's the part that sounds
like the bells and it says one two three
it's the disrupt modern off see
you're a little dumb don't don't and it
says one two three humans very like
crazy Harriet music professors and
talking to you I don't know where that
came from but that oh yeah they're just
trying to make these machine readable
things more readable to humans and it's
just a sudden like legibility is
complicated right it's not just about
knowing how to read or being able to
read something I feel like I recall
reading something you're talking to god
about the roles work attention you know
there's always there's idea of licking
it well you're cutting conceivably you
could learn to read anyway it's good
really you can see that this is like
this doesn't really matter exactly right
leg yeah there's nothing moving there
that there's some of the mess a verra
certain ones where the notes are
supposed to be like right on the holes
and then they actually want to change
because of the roles normally go down
like this and there are a lot of
inventions people got different patents
for the same thing basically it's like
let's turn this sideways now you can
actually read again reading only happens
sideways not right now so if it moves
across this way that you can see in the
music you don't forget um yeah I think
people could read it there's this idea
that it's possible yeah I think so boys
it's question my yards you can you could
train to do it the musical people wanted
to say no you can't do it in the flirt
yeah but then they want to be like and
all that all of the brochure isn't
because like you have to really learn
how to interpret it as you can be a bad
piano listen if you don't know how to
tell what a phrase is about to end you
may slam the pedal down really hard and
hit some notes that supposed to be quiet
super loud wouldn't that be really
embarrassing that's so see ya that's a
that's definitely and what's in the drop
it sort of parallel to that it's with
the phonograph there's a question of why
can you read a Phonographic grooves and
this is well done by a lot of other
sounds
like maybe if i look at it close enough
i can learn it comes out of this like
sound writing thing we could get one
right so this also are like the cone
vibrates of thing in a drazi like this
is what an a looks like a makeover I
can't tell they try to draw one out and
they're like oh that looks the same and
they're artists again for like then we
can make our own music directly on the
program right like pure we can make it
straight like Justin to pure sound
because you can etch your own the roof
sort of true here now I get synthesis
maybe yeah so this may not be a sort of
talk about I should like yeah there you
said you know how we hear thing do you
look at audience or perhaps context in
which should be listening right you like
to play into myself you might not call
that music I can also turn all the other
machine and leave the road is that
performance anymore right it's kind of a
simple stuff like listening to a machine
doing it anyway um that's a that's an
interesting question because a lot of
this is is for me about the sort of
source of these and I had actually
thought about going to that other side
about like the audience side of it where
to Bannock reproduction is not defined
by how you listen to it so much is by
how it's made and of course it's made
thinking that you're going to listen to
in certain ways this similar a similar
kind of thing they both have their
context that they've come from I haven't
thought much about the audience what I
will say is that there is a lot of
thought well this has been other
veterans this is based on the biology of
the year like Helmholtz in the 19th
century or is it how does the ear work
things like this let's make some things
um the the piano lazar based on
technology that has to be built around
about music science that doesn't exist
yet you can't believe the pianist's they
don't know what they're saying even
though they're they're beautiful players
and you want to do that I think what
they do but there's these labs that
there's a section I didn't get to talk
about is objectivity which I really like
which is how do we measure performance
that you decide what the sale
parts are how do you decide in what way
is there salient and it's a lot of
science of that little device that I
showed that the this thing is part of
that it's like how do we measure with
the piano does because is it the speed
of the hammer that makes it louder is it
the speed the key goes down are those
the same or maybe it's different in
console here so there's this
characterizing of the piano as a
scientific knowledge that I think is
really interesting because we made them
like they're not it's like you found it
in the woods in the process they work
but it's a strangely familiar get deep
layer